il y a une chose qui me passionne dans
la vie
c'est le fonctionnement de l'être humain
alors depuis l'âge de 12 ans j'ai
énormément lu de livres de développement
personnel
j'ai fait beaucoup d'études de recherche
et j'ai pris conscience que la plupart
de nos actions de nos réactions de nos
décisions de nos comportements sont
étroitement liés à notre façon de penser
et
que si l'on apporte un peu plus de
positivité dans notre façon de penser il
est possible d'impacter bénéfiquement
nos comportements
alors tout a commencé depuis que j'étais
enfant
j'avais plein de peur
j'avais peur du noir
j'avais peur de l'eau j'avais peur de
prendre la parole en public j'avais peur
des chiens
et toutes ces peurs créant en moi
énormément de blocage de limite
et à un point que ça m'empêchait
tellement de faire de choses qu'il y a
un jour j'ai décidé de dépasser mes
peurs
alors quand
j'étais plus jeune j'avais commencé à me
noyer
j'avais bu la tasse j'ai commencé à
piquer comme un couler comme un piquet
et depuis ce jour-là je croyais que je
ne savais pas nager
et parce que je croyais que je ne savais
pas nager je pensais que si j'allais
aller où je n'avais pas pied j'allais me
noyer
du coup j'avais peur de l'eau d'aller où
je n'avais pas pied et conséquences je
ne faisais aucune activité nautique
jusqu'à ce que j'arrive en Polynésie
ou lorsque j'ai vu tous ces enfants
complètement à l'aise dans l'eau avec à
peine deux trois ans
j'avoue que ça me ça me faisait rêver ça
me donnait envie
et sur ce au même moment j'avais à
l'époque un restaurant sur Montréal et
souvent on avait des clients qui
revenaient l'après-midi des sorties
baleines et qui me racontait que c'était
merveilleux que c'était fantastique et
alors eux ils m'ont donné envie d'aller
voir les baleines
et à partir de là
l'envie d'aller voir les baleines
étaient tellement fortes
que j'ai commencé à
voir autrement mes peurs au lieu de les
voir comme une faiblesse comme des
limites
je les ai vu comme des opportunités de
grandir des opportunités de progresser
parce que je me suis dit si finalement
j'apprends à nager que je suis plus à
l'aise dans l'eau je vais pouvoir faire
plein d'activités chose que pendant 30
ans je n'ai pas fait
et là de les voir positivement j'ai
aussi changé ma façon de me parler et au
lieu d'avoir peur d'aller dans l'eau
j'ai remplacé le j'ai peur par j'ai
envie
alors ça faisait au lieu d'avoir peur
d'aller où je n'avais pas pied je l'ai
remplacé par j'ai envie d'aller voir les
baleines j'ai envie d'être à l'aise dans
l'eau pour aller les voir
et en fait en moi ça a beaucoup changé
au niveau disposition mental parce que
lorsqu'on fait que de se dire j'ai peur
déjà on a peur mais ça nous paralyse
encore plus alors que de mettre dit j'ai
envie ça m'a donné l'élan ça m'a donné
le boost ça a été pour moi un levier de
motivation
et tout est parti de là parce qu'à
partir du moment où j'avais envie d'être
à l'aise dans l'eau j'ai cherché des
solutions j'ai cherché des moyens entre
autres j'ai trouvé un maintenant jeune
j'ai pris des cours et petit à petit
j'ai appris à respirer à être un peu
plus à l'aise dans l'eau et petit à
petit
j'ai osé j'avais 40 ans
c'est toujours on est toujours à temps
d'apprendre n'est-ce pas
et petit à petit j'ai été de plus en
plus à l'aise dans l'eau jusqu'à pouvoir
être capable d'aller voir mes baleines
et
ce jour-là c'était un grand jour pour
moi
puisque
j'étais déjà allé une fois où je n'avais
pas pied mais bon c'était pas forcément
un bon souvenir et tout est parti de là
j'étais vraiment contente bon j'avoue
que ce jour là c'était plus pour moi un
baptême de l'eau que
d'aller voir les baleines moi je les ai
vu quand même elles sont assez grosses
j'y suis retourné une deuxième fois pour
vraiment apprécier les baleines en plus
il y en avait cinq carrément tout
empirer les unes de sous les autres
c'était fabuleux et j'y suis même allée
une troisième fois où j'ai donné la main
à quelqu'un qui avait peur dans l'eau
et tout ça pour dire que les au niveau
des capacités
on peut les acquérir on peut les
développer il s'agit tout d'abord de
croire qu'on est capable d'y arriver
et à partir du moment où vous pensez que
vous êtes capable d'y arriver alors vous
allez développer les ressources pour
réussir je peux vous assurer que là vous
allez développer exploiter tout votre
potentiel cela je vous ai parlé de la
peur de l'eau tout est parti de cette
peur pour moi que j'ai appris à dépasser
et ensuite j'ai appliqué ce processus à
mes autres peurs
et du coup par rapport aux chiens après
m'être fait mordre non seulement par un
chien mais par une meute aujourd'hui je
leur parle
par rapport à ma peur du noir
aujourd'hui je dois je dors dans le noir
complet
quand on a peur de prendre la parole en
public aujourd'hui je suis devant vous
donc là on a parlé au niveau des
capacités maintenant j'aimerais aborder
notre état d'esprit toujours en lien
avec nos émotions et nos comportements
par rapport à des situations
alors
parfois il nous arrive de nous retrouver
dans des situations que l'on n'a pas
voulu que l'on n'a pas désiré que l'on
n'a pas choisi que l'on n'a pas vu venir
que l'on n'a pas pu anticiper
comme par exemple ça peut être une panne
de voiture un voyage qui est annulé
un travail que l'on perd un licenciement
une rupture sentimentale
suite à ça on peut
[Musique]
être mal
souffrir et c'est normal c'est humain
maintenant ce qui est important je
trouve c'est de dépasser cette étape
et là en ce qui me concerne pour vous
raconter une petite anecdote c'est que
au moment où j'avais mon restaurant à
Montréal
il y a un jour du jour au lendemain il
est venu s'installer un concurrent juste
à côté de moi
mais quand même quoi juste à côté de moi
qui faisait à peu près la même carte la
même les mêmes tarifs à peu près la même
clientèle dont vraiment le vrai
concurrent
et
là je faisais que de me dire mais
pourquoi pourquoi il est venu
s'installer juste là pourquoi il fait
exactement la même carte que moi
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi
et là j'ai pris conscience de
l'importance de ce que l'on peut se dire
à ce moment-là et notamment les
questions que l'on peut se poser parce
qu'on se demandant pourquoi c'est bien
de se poser des questions mais après
encore faut-il se poser les bonnes
questions des questions qui vont nous
permettre d'avancer
et je me suis rendu compte que de me
demander toujours pourquoi pourquoi
c'était un petit peu comme si j'étais en
mode victime qui subit qui ne peut rien
faire et en attendant
et bien les clients
avec un peu l'effet d'ouverture ils sont
tous partis chez mon voisin mon chiffre
d'affaires dégringoler
et en attendant
je n'agissais pas et là j'ai commencé à
changer de regard sur les situations et
de me dire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
et du coup j'ai remplacé le pourquoi par
comment
au lieu de me demander pourquoi il est
venu s'installer juste là je me suis
demandé comment avec mon concurrent à
côté je peux quand même rentrer des sous
faire mon chiffre d'affaires
continuez de travailler et en me posant
ces questions ça m'a forcément apporté à
trouver des solutions
et en l'occurrence
à ce moment là au niveau des restaurants
on faisait
le service du midi une coupure
l'après-midi et le service du soir
quasiment tout le restaurant pendant les
hôtels et là je me suis rappelé de mes
sorties baleines et les autres activités
aussi touristiques sur Montréal et comme
les safari ils partent le matin et en
fait ils reviennent vers 13h30 14h ils
n'ont pas mangé et c'est pile l'heure où
les restaurants ils ferment et du coup
je me suis dit bon il y a peut-être un
créneau à prendre
d'ouvrir en fait l'après-midi au moment
où tous les autres fermés et que ses
clients arrivaient alors j'ai essayé et
en fait vous savez quoi j'ai mieux
travaillé l'après-midi que le midi
alors du coup bah j'étais carrément
contente de retrouver les clients de ça
m'a redonné l'énergie la motivation ça
m'a emmené aussi à trouver d'autres
solutions
là quelque part tu
tu te connectes un petit peu à ton
inspiration à ton intuition ta
créativité tu fais appel à des à des
solutions
et
j'ai également trouvé d'autres idées à
exploiter donc là j'ai plutôt exploiter
le potentiel de mon restaurant parce que
il se trouve que j'avais un jardin par
exemple
le jardin en ce moment là il n'était pas
aménagé et du coup je l'ai je l'ai fait
aménager et on a pu faire les apéritifs
dans le jardin c'était le seul jardin à
Montréal du restaurant qui est
accueillait du monde et ça rapportait
encore d'autres clients également
j'avais une scène où je faisais déjà
venir des groupes et du coup j'ai dit
bon qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire
d'autre avec cette scène et j'avais tout
le matériel de la sono et du coup j'ai
fait des retransmissions de matchs et
comme ça plein d'idées qui ont surgi
dans les Landes dans l'énergie et j'ai
carrément mieux travailler en fait à la
fin après
mon concurrent que avant qu'il soit venu
s'installer
et l'idée c'est de se rendre compte
qu'en fait rien qu'en allant chercher
des solutions en se posant les bonnes
questions ça vous permet de reprendre
votre vie en main on vous demandant
comment je peux améliorer la situation
puisque de toute façon elle est là ce
concurrent il est là donc c'est
important de faire quelque chose et du
coup ça me permet de reprendre la vie en
main ou de reprendre son entreprise en
main le cas échéant et du coup vous
redevenez acteur de votre vie
maintenant j'aimerais aborder un dernier
point c'est ce sont nos comportements
par rapport à des personnes alors vous
savez je parle de ces personnes bien
particulières celles qui nous énerve
bien qui éveillent bien tous nos sens
j'ai personnellement j'ai eu beaucoup
autour de moi de personnes assez
autoritaires que ce soit mes ma mère
entre autres et également un ancien
compagnon
et je souffrais beaucoup parce que
je n'osais pas dire non je n'osais pas
poser de limite c'était tout comme lui
il voulait
et j'étais pas bien je souffrais alors
déjà j'étais un peu timide donc de là à
dire non et poser des limites c'était
pas possible enfin je croyais
et là encore une fois j'ai essayé de
changer de regard sur cette personne
parce qu'à ce moment-là je lui en
voulais
j'étais en colère je lui faisais des
reproches et quelque part je cherchais
en fait à le changer puisque pour moi
c'est à cause de lui que j'étais pas
bien sauf que sur les autres on n'a
aucun contrôle
alors je me suis dit ok quelle est la
leçon quelle est l'apprentissage parce
qu'à au même moment j'avais une amie qui
était à peu près dans le même cas de
figure et à qui ce genre de personne ne
posait aucun problème tout simplement
parce qu'elle se défendait
c'est comme ça que je me suis dit bon
c'est peut-être pas lui le problème pas
que
et alors là j'ai je me suis retourné
vers moi intérieurement et je me suis
demandé quelle est la leçon quelle est
l'apprentissage parce que si cette même
personne ne dérange pas quelqu'un
d'autre c'est bien que ça résonne avec
moi
peut-être c'était une ancienne blessure
par rapport à ma mère que j'avais pas
réglé
peut-être que quand j'étais enfant je ne
pouvais pas me défendre
or en tant qu'adulte
aujourd'hui on a le libre arbitre on a
la possibilité de se défendre
de poser des limites
mais je ne savais pas faire je n'avais
jamais fait petite et là je me suis dit
ben il est c'est peut-être ça là le son
alors j'ai appris j'ai appris à m'aimer
davantage à écouter mes besoins avant
les besoins des autres
de manière à me respecter pour me faire
respecter par la suite
et depuis ce jour-là j'ai appris à
m'affirmer
à m'imposer
et je peux vous assurer que ça a
complètement changé mes relations parce
que j'ai compris que quelque part dans
tout interaction dans toute relation
avec quelqu'un on a notre propre
implication
et à partir du moment où tu as ta propre
implication la bonne nouvelle c'est que
tu peux faire quelque chose
et finalement ça m'a permis de grandir
au début c'était à cause de ces
personnes là que j'étais que je
souffrais aujourd'hui je peux dire que
grâce à elle
j'ai évolué
je me suis élevé
et donc pour conclure
je dirais que tous ces apprentissages
toutes ces expériences
mon permis
de devenir
celle que je suis aujourd'hui
dosée être libre libre d'être moi-même
je peux vous assurer que ça fait du bien
ça permet de retrouver toute sa paix ça
sérénité
son enthousiasme sa motivation son
énergie sa joie de vivre
et si j'ai réussi à le faire
vous pouvez le faire aussi
en ayant la certitude
qu'il est possible en changeant d'état
d'esprit
de transformer votre vie
de devenir
le créateur l'artisan
de votre avenir
je dirais même de votre devenir
et pour moi c'est la voix pour mieux
s'accomplir
et s'épanouir
je vous remercie ma Loulou
[Applaudissements]